hey 42 here in 1981
a parisian schoolboy was busy trying to
do something schoolboys the world over
have been attempting for countless
generations
impress his mates but this particular
kid was more inventive than most he
didn't claim to have been on holiday to
area 51
or to be the youngest person in history
to become a black belt in karate
no he claimed to enjoy breaking into
places he shouldn't
after dark nothing too much wrong with
that plenty of kids like bending the
rules when they get the chance
but as is often the way with childhood
boasts
the boy let bravado get the better of
him because he wasn't talking about a
few
surreptitious cigarettes in the car park
of the local leisure center
no he claimed the next place on his list
for a little
nighttime excursion was the pantheon
which just so happens to be one of the
most famous buildings in all of paris
built in the 18th century and originally
a church
the neoclassical marvel that is the
pantheon
is steeped in history it's home to leon
fucker's famous
pendulum with which he completed the
first ever experiment
demonstrating the rotation of the earth
and today
it's used as a mausoleum housing the
remains of some of france's most
celebrated citizens
including voltaire victor hugo alexander
dumas
louis braille and marie curie he was
born in poland but became a french
citizen
later in life after moving to paris so
yeah much like ron burgundy the pantheon
is kind of a big deal the boy's friends
were quick to call what was very
obviously a bluff
but he refused to back down which is how
he and
a small group of friends ended up
sneaking out one night when the rest of
the city was sleeping
to attempt to get inside one of paris's
most famous landmarks
that should have been where this story
ends
with the kids repelled by locked doors
and
patrolling night watchmen this was the
pantheon after all
but much to their surprise getting
inside
was a piece of cake being inside was
equally breezy
and the group spent the night exploring
the utterly deserted national landmark
to their heart's content
without ever running into even a hint of
security
by the time they finally made their way
blearly to bed in the early hours of the
following morning
the same question had crystallized in
each of their minds
where next in most cities their options
would be severely limited
but as you'll know if you've watched my
recent video on the catacombs
paris is no ordinary city the tunnels
that lie hidden beneath its streets
are vast at least 350 kilometers all
told
and to those who know where to look
they offer secret access to the
basements of private residences
government buildings and national
monuments alike
in short the paris catacombs are an
urban explorer's pulsating nocturnal
omission
and according to legend it was during an
adventure in the catacombs
that our group of teenagers stumbled
across a narrow tunnel
packed with electrical cables which they
followed
until eventually finding themselves in
the basement
of what turned out to be the ministry of
communications
again you'd be forgiven for thinking an
important government building like this
would have been protected by laser
sharks and trip wires
okay maybe not that but at least the odd
ageing
guard snoozing on a stool somewhere but
it seems parisians are awfully relaxed
when it comes to security
because the group were able to explore
the basement of the building at their
leisure
and it was there locked away in a dusty
draw
that they were to make a discovery that
would change the history of paris's
underworld
forever a set of maps charting the
entirety of the catacombs for a group of
budding urban explorers
it was the mother lode people had been
exploring the catacombs for untold years
painstakingly mapping new areas and
uncovering
forgotten corners but nobody alive had
managed to build up the kind of
comprehensive overview that was
contained in those pages
secret entrances to the catacombs that
had been lost for generations
entire tunnel systems as yet on explores
and of course underground access points
to many of paris's most famous landmarks
armed with this sacred knowledge le ux
as the group of friends would come to be
known have been causing
absolute mayhem in paris ever since
fast forward to today and layux which is
short for
the urban experiment have grown into a
fully-fledged underground organization
in both the literal and figurative sense
figuratively underground because they
operate under a cloak of extreme secrecy
and literally underground because it's
their unique knowledge of the catacombs
that has allowed them to pull off the
kinds of stunts usually reserved for
plot lines in hollywood blockbusters
by the way if the name layux sounds
familiar that might be because i briefly
touched on the organization
in my video about the catacombs these
were the guys who built an entire cinema
complex deep beneath the streets of
paris
complete with bar and restaurant where
they are forced to have held film
festivals
and private screenings for months maybe
even years before french police
eventually stumbled across the setup
during a training exercise
but while building a secret cinema in a
cave system below one of the world's
great cities
is pretty damn cool it's just the tip of
the lei ux iceberg
so what would you do if someone gave you
what amounted to
a skeleton key granting access to some
of the most famous buildings in the
world
through a series of little-known secret
entrances
this is paris we're talking about here
pretty much everywhere you look there
are priceless works of art hanging on
gallery walls
sellers stocked with dusty bottles of
vintage wine
and museums chock full of rare artifacts
i don't know about you but i'd be
robbing the place blind
you wouldn't be able to move in the 42
residence for monets and half drunk
bottles of cheval blanc
but not lay ux in fact
over the last few decades far from
stealing everything in sight
they've kind of been doing the opposite
you see
they're of the opinion french officials
have
at times been a little negligent in
their attitude
towards the country's rich heritage
focusing tax dollars only on the upkeep
of big-ticket tourist traps like
the louvre and the eiffel tower whilst
letting
less well-known sides slowly deteriorate
or even fall into ruin so
instead of pulling off a series of art
heists worthy of the thomas crown affair
lei ux decided to become the invisible
champions of paris's lost heritage
both above ground and below
they're responsible for secret
restorations of at least
one forgotten metro station a 12th
century crypt
a 100 year old french government bunker
and a world war ii air raid shelter of
course
that kind of work takes both manpower
and expertise
and lei ux has grown considerably since
those early days
when it was just a group of friends
having a bit of fun
fought to be made up of at least 150
members today
the group is now split across several
different units
each with its own special skills and
equally
special name there's the mouse house who
focus on
infiltration the untegunta who carry out
covert restorations of heritage sites
around the city
and la mexican de perfracion who were
responsible for their secret cinema
complex
as well as countless other excavations
in the catacombs
but whilst the names are playful lee ux
are
deadly serious in their mission of
stepping in where the state is failing
to take care of paris's rich history
as well as reclaiming lost and forgotten
spaces for
creative expression usually in the
catacombs themselves
where they regularly host secret art
exhibitions
and film screenings in 2006
a lone thief managed to waltz inside the
parisian museum of modern art
helping himself to paintings by the
likes of picasso modeliani and matisse
before escaping entirely undetected if
you read the newspaper coverage at the
time
you'd be forgiven for thinking this was
some kind of elaborate heist pulled off
by
sophisticated international art thieves
but as we've seen
security at some of paris's most famous
landmarks
isn't always quite what you'd expect and
in reality the theft was pulled off by
some bloke who ambled up to the museum
in the dead of the night
broke one padlock and smashed a single
window
that was literally all it took to grant
the guy
access to hundreds of millions of euro
worth of paintings
the robbery was nothing to do with lee
ux as i've said they're in the business
of preserving heritage not pinching it
but they have been doing their bit to
try and ensure
similar robberies never happen again by
keeping an eye on museum security across
the city
and stepping in when they find issues so
collectively they're like french batman
but instead of causing millions of euros
of property damage and hospitalizing
just about everyone in sight to stop a
lone body
layux prefer to fix what's broken and
take a more intelligent approach to
vigilantism
one member carried out a detailed audit
of one of paris's leading museums over a
series of weeks
finding multiple problems with the level
of security she observed
she wrote a full report on the various
issues
explaining the myriad ways she could
have broken into the museum
and made off of some swag had she chosen
to do so
when she'd finished presumably both to
save on postage and to
ably demonstrate her point she
infiltrated the office of the museum's
head of security
in the middle of the night and left the
report
on his desk you'd think the man would
have been grateful for the help when he
came in the next morning
if perhaps a little embarrassed by where
it came from
but no he wasn't grateful
he was angry so angry in fact he went
straight to the police to press charges
talk about looking a gift horse in the
mouth the police declines to pursue the
matter any further
without a doubt lei ux's crowning
achievement
or at least a crowning achievement
amongst the ones we actually know about
took place back where it all started at
the pantheon
which as it turns out had become
something of a second home
to the members of layux over the years
since that first night the group had
been back many
many times and not just to wander around
admiring the 19th century architectural
flourishers as crazy as it sounds not
content with simply infiltrating
one of the city's most famous landmarks
lay ux members
had four years been using the cavernous
interior
as their own private after-hours
exhibition center
hosting art installations staging plays
and filming screenings there in the dead
of the night
then clearing everything away and
disappearing without a trace
before the taurus turned up the next day
if you find that hard to believe
you don't have to take my word for it
because layux kindly went to the trouble
of producing a short film of their
exploits called pantheon
user guide in which you can watch a
layux member in an untogunter t-shirt
enjoying a pleasant evening
rollerblading around a deserted pantheon
before other team members arrived to rig
up a huge projector for a private
screening
of american psycho all without staff at
the mausoleum
ever being any the wiser it was probably
during one of these events in november
of 2005
that someone decided to go and take a
look at one of the pantheon's greatest
treasures an antique wagner clock
which was built in 1850 to preside over
a prominent entrance within the building
butts had been allowed to fall into
disrepair
one of lay ux's members happened to be a
qualified watchmaker
for renowned french horological house
brege
and on taking a look at the piece he
discovered
it wasn't simply old and dirty someone
had deliberately
sabotaged the movement presumably to
save them the trouble of winding it
every day
if the pontian administration weren't
going to look after such a precious
piece under their care
it was time for the unto gunter lee ux's
specialist restoration unit
to step in but this was no simple spruce
up of a forgotten crypt beneath
the city the wagner clock was an
important artifact of one of paris's
most popular buildings
visited by hundreds of thousands of
tourists each year
the clock's mechanism was large and
complicated
and it would need to be taken apart and
thoroughly cleaned
with the damaged parts repaired or
replaced
and seeing as the work would have to be
carried out in secrets during the night
they were going to need months to
complete the job not to mention
plenty of equipment more than they could
simply bring
in and out every night put all of these
things together and it should have been
an impossible job but the hunter gunter
were more than a match for it
to kick things off they built themselves
a fully functioning secret workshop
in a cavity high up in the pantheon
hidden beneath the great dome
which they kitted out with armchairs
bookshelves
and a small bar and because they love a
silly name
they dubbed it the unter and gunter
vinta canipa
german for the unter and gunter winter
boozer
they even set up a small vegetable
garden on a terrace overlooking the city
because getting your five a day
shouldn't be compromised
even if you are busy covertly restoring
an aging artifact
right under the nose of the french
government the restoration took
almost a year with the clock
painstakingly restored to its former
glory
typically lee ux act in complete secrecy
we have no way of knowing how many such
restorations they've made across the
city
but this time was different after all in
order for their hard work to be
worthwhile
somebody was going to have to keep the
wagner clock wound
so for once breaking protocol
leux surfaced arranging a meeting with
the administrator of the pantheon to
tell him the good news
you're probably thinking the man was
absolutely delighted to hear
an important part of the pantheon's
history had been repaired
completely free of charge by a
horological expert
and rumor has it he was for all of about
15 seconds
at which point he didn't so much look
his gift horse in the mouth
but attempted to get it sent straight to
the glue factory
apparently coming to the conclusion the
whole thing was going to make him look
incompetent
after all not one member of his staff
reported seeing anything out of the
ordinary
during the entire year it had taken for
the team to restore the clerk
the man promptly initiated legal action
against those involved
with the prosecutors seeking up to a
year in jail on top of almost 50 000
euro in damages
despite the fact lee ux had invested
some 4 000 euro of their own money
on the restoration the pantheon even
hired another clock maker
to undo the unto gunter's repairs
although he refused to actively damage
the mechanism
deactivating it instead unfortunately
for the pantheon administration it seems
there are no laws in france against
secretly repairing clocks in the middle
of the night
so instead they went after layux for
something else entirely
inside a year four members of the
underguns have found themselves in the
paris court of justice
not on charges of breaking and entering
or of repairing a priceless clock
but for apparently breaking a lock
somewhere on the pantheon
grounds it was a ridiculous case in many
many ways not least because there was
absolutely no proof under gunter members
had actually broken the lock in the
first place but
thankfully the french legal system came
through with flying colours on this one
after hearing the trial the judge
deliberated for only 20 minutes
before revealing his verdict not guilty
with one of the prosecutors quoted as
calling the whole case
stupid my grasp on french law is pretty
basic
but i think the judge came to his
decision based on reasoning along the
lines of
we don't guillotine the good guys monami
[ __ ] of me more like in the kind of two
finger salutes they're now famous for
lei ux infiltrated the pantheon once
more in the wake of the trial
reactivating the wagner clock so that it
would chime
for a few days over the christmas period
before returning once again
to remove the components they'd repaired
just in case the current administration
hired anyone else to break it what's so
intriguing about leux is that
everything we know about them the
remarkable restoration of the pantheon
clock
the mysterious security reports designed
to protect important art galleries
the infiltration and the subterranean
events
these things just scratch the surface of
their clandestine activities beneath
paris
they are after all an underground
organization
and they don't publicize almost anything
they do
what we do know about them has often
come out inadvertently when
someone they've tried to help has
reacted with about as much grace as
bambi after 15 pints of newcastle brown
ale
on the rare occasions lay ux members
have spoken to the press
they've always hinted at other equally
ambitious projects they're working on
that never make it into the public
domain but if you think all of this
sounds like kind of a good time
i'm afraid there's no easy way of
joining glare ux
just to add a little more to their
mystique becoming a member
is by invitation only and only those who
are
already involved in lay ux like
activities
will ever receive an invite so yeah if
you want to join
you basically have to go to paris get
yourself underground
sharpish and start causing all sorts of
mischief until some suave looking
stranger taps you on the shoulder in a
coffee shop
and teaches you the secret handshake
well i guess that's my summer holiday
sorted
thanks for watching you can now buy my
new book stick a flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you